eigentlich bin ich ganz anders ich komme
nur so selten dazu es gibt sie diese
tage wochen vielleicht sogar jahre in
denen wir fern von uns sind fern von
anderen ja der welt selbst was macht ein
wirkliches leben aus und wie
funktioniert das sich selbst
verwirklichen fragen denen der in zürich
lehrende philosoph michael hampe oft
anzeigen auch literarische weise nach gt
rampe herzlich willkommen in der
sternstunde
vielen dank danke für die einladung
eigentlich nicht ganz anders ich komme
nur selten dazu dass ein sehr schönes
wort von ödön von horvath dem dichter
haben sie denn in einer phase ihres
lebens auch einmal so über sich gedacht
und empfunden
ja also so wie alle menschen das in der
regel ab und zu mal haben hat mich als
jugendlicher und vielleicht so vor 56
jahren
dieser zustand auch beschlichen und es
ist ein zustand der etwas mit der
pubertät und der lebensmittel zu tun hat
in der regel manchmal auch mit dem
lebensende sind es die erfahrung dass
man sagt in den spiegel schaut und sagt
das bin doch gar nicht ich das ist gar
nicht mein leben zumindest nicht dass
das ich führen will
ja vielleicht ist es manchmal so einer
spiegel szene häufig hat es damit zu tun
dass man bestimmte handlungen in rollen
immer wieder durch führt und sich fragt
ob man eigentlich zu der rolle die man
ausgefüllt hat passt das ist vielleicht
eher die situation der lebensmitte und
was man so mit vergleichsweise ist ja
und die situation der pubertät ist etwas
anders weil man da merkt überhaupt erst
das rollenerwartungen an einen
herangetragen werden aber man sich
selbst noch nicht genau wie noch kennen
die eigenen möglichkeiten die eigenen
wünsche noch nicht kennt und das dann
als der zudringlichkeit in der regel auf
fast dass die eltern die lehrer einen
fragen aber es wird schlimmer werden und
ich glaube das kannst du gut willst
nicht das machen und so weiter also job
zumutungen freundschaft zumutung
vielleicht und weil man sich noch nicht
genau genug kennt ergibt sich dann ein
bedürfnis sich davon zu distanzieren und
erst mal wenn es gut läuft
herauszufinden was für möglichkeiten und
wünsche man eigentlich hat also als
einen maßgeblichen entfremdung sgr
und/oder impuls könnte man sagen das
sind die anderen menschen und die
erwartungen dieser nein herantrat und
das gefühl die wollen etwas von mir was
mir nicht entspricht
ja das setzt voraus dass da etwas ist
dass sich verwirklichen will und dass
eventuell durch die soziale situation an
der verwirklichung gehindert wird das
ist vielleicht das standardmodell
es ist vielleicht auch ein modell dass
viele von uns im kopf haben aber ich
selbst würde es nicht für besonders
plausibel halten dass da etwas ist was
nach verwirklichung strebt sie haben ja
diesen wunsch oder auch der frage was es
heißt wirklich zu leben sich selbst zu
verwirklichen jetzt ein eigenes buch
gewidmet die seele die wildnis und das
nichts
wie weit würden sie denn sagen ist das
verbreitet in der gesellschaft ist das
eine minderheiten erfahrung oder ist das
eine sehr breite erfahrung
ja das ist von gesellschaft zu
gesellschaft unterschiedlich würde ich
vermuten
also ich habe jetzt keine sozial
statistiken studiert aber die
aufforderung sich selbst zu
verwirklichen ist in den westlichen
gesellschaften in der reichen nord
westlichen gesellschaften glaube ich
relativ verbreitet ich denke in
asiatischen gesellschaften ist das
anders
wie das in afrika ist weiß ich nicht
also ist denke ich ein normativer
anspruch
der sowohl zeitlich wie auch kulturell
relativ eingegrenzt ist also ich glaube
das gab es früher bei uns in europa
nicht in der form in der es in das heute
existiert und ich denke in anderen
kulturen gibt es das wenige aber sofern
die die europäische und amerikanische
kultur sich auf dem ganzen globus
ausbreitet ist es vielleicht ein
phänomen was immer mehr menschen
betrifft
man könnte es ja als den wunsch den
tisch zu sein oder ein tisch zu wirken
beschreiben da gibt es ja in der werbung
jede menge imperative mach dein ding
seit selbst just do it be on you can be
das könnte auf den gedanken bringen dass
das nicht nur eine spezifisch moderne
erfahrung ist sondern auch eine markt
getrieben
ja ich weiß nicht ob das markt getrieben
sondern ich habe den eindruck die märkte
oder unternehmen benutzen dieses
bedürfnis um ihr produkt als etwas was
die selbstverwirklichung befördert zu
platzieren nicht also es ist nicht so
dass die einen quasi in der
selbstverwirklichung befördern wollen
sondern sie wollen ihren wein oder ihr
auto loswerden und sagen das ist genau
der wein der zu dir passt und das ist
das auto zu wer das verpasst sie docken
an das begehren angenommen ja also aber
ich glaube nicht dass sie tatsächlich
etwas mit diesem kulturellen phänomenen
in seiner entstehung zu tun haben
sondern dass daher rückkopplungseffekt
entstanden ist dass sie in der werbung
gemerkt haben dass das ein bedürfnis ist
dass sich ausbreitet und man es benutzen
kann um ein produkt ein mann oder die
frau zu bringen
eine klassisch philosophische weise
diese erfahrung auf einen begriff zu
bringen ist der ruf die berufung man
hörte ein ruf aus sich selbst heraus und
ein besonders vielversprechender ort
diesen ruf der selbstverwirklichung zu
folgen ist die wildnis man geht in die
wildnis um sich selbst zu finden der
berghof gremien wie was ist denn das für
eine erwartung dass man ausgerechnet in
der wildnis ein besseres selbst finden
kann
sie schreibt mir davon auch das ist der
erste große teile sind die wildnis ja
das hat damit zu tun dass die diese
erwartungen eben soziale erwartungen
sind und dass da wo
an anderen menschen sind und keine stadt
ist und man keinen job hat die
erwartungen wegfallen und dann kann man
sich überlegen wie füllt man jetzt
dieses vakuum das durch den wegfall der
sozialen ansprüche entstanden ist und
ich würde sagen in der spätromantik und
dem zwanzigsten jahrhundert ist dass
selbst eine technik geworden also man
geht in die wildnis um sich zu befreien
von den sozialen ansprüchen und dann
schaut man was sich öffnet was aus einem
kommt und hofft dass die authentischen
wünsche die die pläne das was man
eigentlich ist ein selbstbewusst und
dass er ein sehr berühmter vorgänger
klassisches modell henry david thoreau
mit wolken der in dieser hütte in den
wald geht und an allen menschen und von
der gesellschaft eine auszeit zu nehmen
und sich selbst zu finden
es gibt ja diesen schönen spruch mensch
gegen dich war ich schon ist auch nichts
luft also ist denn das 1 1 modell wo sie
sagen dass es viel versprechend oder
dass es von vornherein ein bisschen irre
geleitet
ja ich glaube es ist letztlich ihre
irregeleitet also nicht nicht von
vornherein ich glaube schon dass das
einen wichtigen effekt hat sich von
sozialen kontexten möglichst lange zeit
mal zu befreien
aber es wird nicht dazu führen dass der
eigene wesenskern ans licht kommt
sondern es führt dazu dass man schärfer
wahrnimmt in welchem kontext man
eigentlich existiert also es gibt ja die
standard erfahrung dass man ins ausland
reist in eine andere kultur und dann
wenn man in die eigene kultur
zurückkommt die regeln viel schärfer
wahrnimmt unter denen man bisher
existiert hat und der golden pond war
eine präparierte wildnis würde ich mal
sagen also das war jetzt nicht eine
echte wildnis mit wilden tieren mit der
ort an dem büro dieses haus findet er ja
so dass ich sagen würde
also urlaub vom leben wenn man wenn man
diese musische formulierung benutzen
möchte war so etwas zwischen einer
fernreise und einem wirklich in die
wildnis gegenlicht die wildnis hat noch
ein anderes versprechen sie ist
gefährlich in ihr kann man sich beweisen
haben sie dann auch mal wenn sie diese
phasen hatten gesagt ich versuche es mal
in der wildnis biografisch zu sehen wer
ich sein kann und jetzt bin ja ja das
war was war in der pubertät dass ich da
mir sehr sehr unsicher war was ich was
ich machen möchte und auch die
familiären verhältnisse im jahr quasi
unklar geworden sind und ich bin dann
mit einem schulfreund nach lappland
gegangen und wir haben uns da 14 tage
jenseits des disq ums leben wie das
heißt es ist der wanderweg der da
durchführt aufgehalten und das war schon
aus dem bedürfnis heraus zu finden ob
wir das schaffen also ob wir es schaffen
uns orientieren ob wir es schaffen nur
von nahrungsmitteln die wir auf dem
rücken tragen 14 tage zu leben ob wir
über ein gletscher übergehen können die
sind ja sehr tief da ohne dass wir
vorher um die bergsteigerische erfahrung
gehabt haben und so und es ist dann auch
nicht besonders gut ausgegangen muss ich
sagen hat es dann eine gefährliche
situation ja ja also ich habe mich
verletzt und musste musste rausgeholt
werden mit dem mit einem hubschrauber
und mein weinfreund musste alleine
zurückgehen um alarm zu schlagen
es gibt ja auch wildnis profis extrem
erfuhren wir hören uns mal aus einem
gespräch in der sternstunde den
extrembergsteiger reinhold messner an
die erfahrungen die er in diesen
besteigungen sucht wir gehen ja
freiwillig aus der zivilisierten welt
die relativ sicher ist der mensch tut
seit 10.000 jahren nichts anderes als
die welt seine urbane umgebung sicherer
und sicher und sicher zu machen
da gehen wir hinaus in eine
menschenfeindliche welt wo man umkommen
könnte
um nicht umzukommen das ist ja das ist
wichtiger dass diese möglichkeit bleibt
um zu kommen wenn die möglichkeit nicht
die möglichkeit um zu kommen nicht
vorhanden ist ist das ganze nur ein
spiel aber wenn die möglichkeit
umzukommen gegeben ist dann gehe ich ja
gegen meine instinkte in die wildnis
sich die instinkte wollten das nicht sie
sagen du hast angst und ich habe auch
angst und sorgen trotzdem durch sich
gegen den selbsterhaltungstrieb das ist
der stärkste trieb den wir haben da
hinauf um nicht umzukommen und wenn es
mir gelingt nicht umzukommen ist das
anschließend wie eine wiedergeburt
das steht ja fast schon wie eine art
rezeptur gibt dich in zonen der
todesnähe bestehe sie und dann bist du
das neue selbst dass du immer sein
wolltest ja er sagt ja nur wiedergeburt
ist und das ist halt die frage ob dann
das eigentliche das wahre selbst
wiedergeboren wird oder ob dasselbe
selbst was vorher da war wiedergeboren
wird aber der hinweis darauf dass man
sich in todesgefahr begeben muss der ist
glaube ich relativ wichtig in dem in dem
kontext deshalb denke ich dass soros
aufenthalt am golden pond im sinne von
messner eigentlich ein spiel war weil er
also er hätte sich schon sehr
anstrengend ist und dein lebensgefahr zu
geraten wenn es jetzt einen teich
gefallen wäre wäre ich nicht so viel
passiert
diese sich in todes gefahr begeben
wollen könnte damit zusammenhängen dass
man die sicherheitsmechanismen die von
der gesellschaft produziert werden als
etwas ansieht was dazu führt dass man
sich selbst unterschätzt und dass man
den eigenen möglichkeiten eingeschränkt
wird was vor allen dingen bei
jugendlichen die sich sehr stark und
munter fühlen der fall dass wir eltern
sagen ja nun macht mal eine
beamtenlaufbahn ja da kriegst du kein
gehalt pünktlich und orientierte
existenzen debattierte erklären ist und
dass das
dann denkt man ja die sind ja über
ängstlich die eltern die wollen mich in
watte packen und ich kann doch was ganz
anderes und die herauszufinden was man
eigentlich kann das ist am besten
möglich wenn man in lebensgefahr gerät
wenn man dann alle kräfte mobilisiert
das scheint ja noch der andere idee
dahinter zu sein nämlich dass es in
ausnahmesituationen der existenz etwas
gibt was sich dann zeigt ein
mutmaßlicher land man kann sagen so eine
art ideologie der ausnahmesituation
ja da zeigt sich wer ich wirklich bin ja
ja das finde ich eine problematische
eine problematische idee
ich weiß nicht ob angemessen die nahe
legen wollte die gibt es übrigens nicht
nur in bezug auf die wildnis gibt es
auch in bezug auf den krieg also meine
meine großeltern und eltern sind im
zweiten weltkrieg schwierigen
situationen ausgesetzt gewesen und ich
habe öfter sowohl von meinem vater wie
auch von meinem großvater gehört dass
sich in einer bedrohungssituation
gezeigt hat ob jemand tauglich oder
nicht tauglich ist ob er ein feigling
oder kein feigling ist und dass sich das
wesen einer person dann quasi in der
kampfhandlungen die lebensbedrohlich
gewesen es gezeigt hat aber warum soll
diese situation das wesen zeigen und der
gemütlichen kaffeeklatsch bei denen
jemand nette witze erzählt nicht zu dem
wesen dieser person gehören also das ist
quasi die vorstellung sie mehr druck ich
aus über auf eine person sei es durch
durch kriegerische bedrohung sei es
durch natürliche bedrohungen in der
wildnis umso näher komme ich an den kern
der person dran und das ist meiner
ansicht nach durch eine metapher ihre
geleitete gedanken figur
es ist ja auch etwas das klang jetzt
auch schon ein bisschen ein männlicher
wunsch die mich beweisen mich an anderen
dass es um die einen kampf mit der
wildnis herr messner spricht sogar dafür
dass er sich selbst noch mal zur welt
bringt man ja sagen es ein bisschen
narzisstisch er ist doch schon auf der
welt wurde von einer frau auf die welt
geworfen
glauben sie dass diese erfahrung der
neugeburt
in todesnähe vielleicht sogar eher ein
männlicher als ein weiblicher wunsch es
ja so ist sich sicher ein wunsch der der
etwas mit tierischen idealen zu tun hat
und sofern männliche charaktere immer
noch reste von solchen heroischen selbst
bildern mit sich führen wollen sie
helden der natur oder kriegshelden sein
und die die leute die zuerst den den
mount everest bestiegen haben haben
quasi auch kriegs orden auf dem rückweg
von der britischen königin verliehen
bekommen so als würden sie von einem
schlachtfeld zurückkehren man sprach ja
damals auch davon dass man den berg
bezwingt als würde man sich quasi bei
einer bei einer extrem bergsteiger ein
eine kampfhandlung begeben und die
wildnis ein gegner sein das ist das
natürlich auch einfach eine
metaphorische ausmalung der
anstrengungen der sich diese leute
befinden de facto will einem der berg ja
nichts böses
da ist ja keine intensität die sich
gegen einrichtet aber die vorstellung
dass man ein held ist wenn man das
geschafft hat ich glaube wir alle
betrachten ein und messen als einen
helden
er hat etwas vollbracht was wir uns
nicht trauen würden vielleicht also ich
finde ihn jetzt sich zu nahe treten aber
doch doch sind sie richtig und viel mut
aufzubringen entbehrungen zu überstehen
ist etwas was wir hoch schätzen
es gibt ja noch andere techniken sich
selbst zu suchen man könnte sagen es ist
sogar nur versprechen des
philosophierens dass sie einen auf ein
auf eine höhere wirklichkeit hin
transformieren sowohl in bezug auf die
wirklichkeit die da draußen sein mag als
auch auf die wirklichkeit meines eigenen
selbst würde sagen das ist eigentlich
der ruf der philosophie zu werden der
mann ist zumindest der westlichen
philosophie wie sie vor allen dingen
durch den platonisch muss geprägt worden
ist also diese berühmte platonische
erzählung von dem heraus krabbeln aus
der höhle und dass wir eingesperrt sind
und nur schatten sehen die eigentlich
gar nicht die wirklichkeit sind
ist eine geschichte die genau davon
handelt was er jetzt beschreiben dass
man die wirklichkeit selbst in form des
ursprünglichen lichtes sid und wenn man
dieses ursprüngliche licht gesehen hat
auch weiß wer man selbst ist und die
figur des sokrates ist da quasi an ein
vorbild geworden
naja dem in petri folgt erkenne dich
selbst genau erfolgt im imperativ sich
selbst zu erkennen und ist ein dauer
frager befragt andere befragt sich
selbst und erreicht durch diese
philosophische technik wenn man das so
sagen will
einen ungewöhnlichen zustand der ruhe
und der autonomie der sich dann zeigt
als er in der todeszelle mit seinen
freunden weiterhin gespräche für die
wirtin sterblichkeit nicht in panik
gerät in schillings becher trinkt sich
hinlegt ruhig beobachtet wie langsam die
kälte von den füßen aufsteigt zum herzen
und dann sagt opfert dem asklepios ein
hahn und stirbt also quasi völlig coolen
das würde dann würde man heute sagen
habe extrem cool und natürlich auch wer
die idee dass sie sich am tod am sterben
beweist ob man die natur gefunden hat
genau also die sie deshalb meinte ich am
anfang dass diese krisensituation sich
selbst zu suchen
in der pubertät in der lebensmitte und
manchmal eben auch am lebensende
eintritt weil es philosophen gibt also
montani wäre auch so eine an eine figur
die der meinung sind dass die panik die
am lebensende eintritt nicht allein die
panik ist von der reinhold messer
gesprochen hat dass die selbsterhaltung
nicht mehr funktioniert sondern es
könnte auch die panik sein dass sich das
falsche leben geführt habe und es jetzt
nicht mehr ändern kann weil es dieses
falsche leben vorbei ist und das
richtige nicht mehr begonnen werden kann
so dass quasi die reue das leben
verfehlt zu haben ein weiterer grund
für einen unruhigen tot sein kann und
wenn so gut es eben völlig ruhig stirbt
dann könnte man zu der auffassung kommen
er hat es geschafft
das wäre ja fast interpretation dieses
anderen großen satzes von monterrey
philosophieren heißt sterben lernen dass
man so lebt dass man in ruhe sterben
kann weil man sich selbst gefunden genau
ja also dass man durch die durch die
konfrontation mit dem tod sich nicht
mehr im leben zusammen hänge zwingen
lässt die man nicht für richtig hält so
dass quasi des todes bewusst sein
ein mögliches kriterium dafür ist ob ich
wirklich das leben führe das ich führen
muss oder führen will
weil wenn ich nicht mehr viel zeit habe
dann das irgendwie auch nichts mehr ein
was nicht zu mir passt
sie loten ja in diesem buch ein wenig
die bedingungen der möglichkeit und
unmöglichkeit dieser selbstfindung aus
und das eine was ja vorausgesetzt ist in
dem imperativ erkenne dich selbst dass
es da etwas gibt was man überhaupt
finden kann gibt eine sehr schöne
beobachtung in diesem buch nämlich dass
das griechische wort für die seele oder
das selbst psyche auch ein wort für
schmetterlinge ist wie kommt das was ist
der gedanke dahinter dass diese
übertragung überhaupt möglich ist in
kritischen denken also wie das
etymologisch tatsächlich gelaufen ist
das weiß ich auch nicht müssen wir ehren
altphilologen fragen aber dass das der
schmetterling als seelen symbol benutzt
wird hat meiner ansicht nach mit
bestimmten unsterblichkeit vorstellungen
zu tun also dass das kommt auch bei
platten vor
so hat er sagt in diesen berühmten
dialog am ende seines lebens empfunden
dass der leib ein gefängnis ist und der
tod die befreiung der seele aus dem leib
lichen gefängnis und der schmetterling
stammt ja aus der auto ab und die raupe
verpuppt sich und dann bricht sie die
puppe auf und dann fliegt der schönen
schmetterling hinaus und sokrates sagt
dass die seele dann wieder dahin kommt
wo sie eigentlich hingehört und wo sie
schon gewesen ist zur wahrheit
zum 1 1 und licht und wenn man das jetzt
bewerten will zoologisch könnte man
sagen da gibt es diese hässliche väter
auch die darum kriegt das sind jetzt wir
das sind wir als lebende und dann gibt
es den moment des todes
das ist die 1 punkt und diese ein punkt
ist aber nicht das ende sondern dann
kommt quasi eine wiedergeburt in einem
höheren zustand als wenn das wirkliche
leben genau dann kommt das wirkliche
leben der schmetterling ist das
wirkliche wesen und die raupe ist nur
die vorstufe zum schmetterling das ist
natürlich eine beleidigung der am hofe
aber so kann man das ja sehen sie auch
eine beleidigung unsere existenzen
abwertung kann ja sagen
man könnte sagen sokrates wertet die lag
das ist ja auch es ja immer wieder
kritisiert worden also nietzsches
paragraf im zarathustra über die
verächter des leibes richtet sich genau
auf dieses problem also sozusagen das
wirkliche leben beginnt erst wenn die
seele vom leib befreit wird bedeutet
dass die leibliche existenz eine eine
untergeordnete eine vorstufe eine
niedrigere ist es gibt vielleicht noch
einen anderen gedanken bei diesen
schmetterling nämlich der schmetterlinge
wandelt sich er transformiert sich wie
man sich in der selbstfindung ja auch
selbst transformieren sollten sie
bringen das fast auf einer art grund
widersprüchlichkeit des abendländischen
denkens zwei annahmen über das selbst
das eine ist etwas konstantes das
vorliegt das andere ist es etwas was
noch nicht vorliegt und geschaffen
werden muss zwei völlig unvereinbare
konzepte der selbsterkenntnis
ja ja und da ist auch der schmetterling
finde ich eine interessante metapher war
wenn sie ihn genau angucken dann sehen
sie ja dass das denn dass der
schmetterlinge immer noch die raupe ist
also es ist also immer das dann unter
der lupe ankommen da sieht man ja dass
der fette warum in der mitte existiert
und dem sind eine große flügel gewachsen
nicht also es ist ja nicht so dass wir
da wurden ist nicht weg er worum es
nicht mehr genau also dass selbst also
die transformation ist keine
vollständigen erinnern und das denken
wir uns ja auch in christlich
platonischen vorstellung dass das
wirkliche selbst was
in der unsterblichkeit dann ans licht
kommt irgendwie in kontinuität zu dem
eingesperrten selbst was ich nicht
richtig bewusst war als es in diesem
leib existieren musste steht also wir
gehen wir verschwinden nicht in dieser
transformation soll es eine
transformation die auch gleichzeitig
eine kontinuität darstellt und darin
steckt glaube ich die
widersprüchlichkeit sozusagen
da gibt es ein vorleben dass ein bloßer
schein ist und dann gibt es das wahre
leben dass kein schein mehr ist aber
gleichzeitig besteht eine kontinuität
zwischen den beiden das führt in große
philosophische verwirrung die meiner
ansicht nach nicht auflösbaren sind ein
anderes modell der selbstfindung bei dem
man gar nicht so viel tun muss ist das
der liebe ich werde erkannt und befreit
durch jemand anderen
das heißt jemand anders sieht für mich
wer ich bin und entpuppt nicht ja ja ja
das ist natürlich oft vor allen dingen
in verliebtheit zuständen mit
narzisstischen projektionen verbunden
nicht man möchte erkannt werden dann
möchte als ein unverwechselbares lesen
erkannt werden und dann tritt man quasi
in einen kurzschluss ein dass man diesen
wunsch auf die andere person projiziert
und die projiziert diesen wunsch auf
einen selbst und dann zeichnet man sich
gegenseitig als diejenigen aus die als
erste erkannt haben wer man wirklich ist
und das funktioniert eine weile aber wie
wir alle wissen nicht sehr lange nicht
also irgendwann mal das gefühl da hat
mich ja doch nicht erkannt sonst wäre ja
nicht plötzlich enttäuscht oder würde
finde ich sollte etwas anderes machen
und dann bricht quasi sage dieser
kurzschluss ab
und dann merkt man dass das vielleicht
gar kein gutes modell ist höre ich da
eine gewisse skepsis heraus dass der
andere nicht das mittel zur
selbsterkenntnis sein kann sondern dass
man das schon wenn überhaupt selbst
machen muss ja also ich glaube dass dass
es zwei arten von von lieben gibt dass
es die liebe gibt die mit dieser großen
erwartungen verbunden ist dass man in
seiner wahrheit oder wirklichkeit
erkannt wird und es gibt die liebe die
damit zu tun hat dass jemand anderes
einem wohl will was immer auch erscheint
also dass er quasi nicht taugt und sagte
ach das bist du wirklich und das finde
ich ganz toll wusste da wirklich ist
sondern dass er jetzt in einem etwas
emphatischen sinne einen sein lässt
einen sein lässt wie man ist also wie
man erscheint nicht ich will dass du
weißt was immer du bist das wäre diese
form ist dieser liebe so kann man
schildern oder dass man das kommt bei
verschiedenen philosophen und dichtern
auch 19 und 20 jahrhundert vor dass man
sich kein bildnis macht dass man
akzeptiert dass wir nicht in der lage
sind diese unterscheidung zwischen
zufälligen schein und eigentlicher
wirklichkeit tatsächlich zu machen
es ist eine mischung aus skepsis und
wohlwollen die eine vielleicht nicht so
aufregende form der liebe ist aber die
vielleicht bekömmlicher ist als der
kurzschluss ja auch die wesens
erkenntnisse aus das ist ja fast schon
eine eine eine eheberatung des textes
und wohlwollen so kommt man miteinander
aus das nehme ich mal mit
es gibt natürlich aber auch dank
maltechniken der individualisierung der
selbstfindung und auch bereich unserer
kulturen dienen das besonders
prominentes die kunst zum beispiel das
sind die mathematischen individuen
wir haben neulich den pianisten igor
levit ihr zu gast gehabt und er hat
darüber gesprochen was es braucht um so
zu klingen wie man selbst und haben uns
mal kurz
ich mag beim musik machen wenn es wenn
es in anführungszeichen leicht und
direkt kommt ja und das ist das
allerschwerste miles davis hat gesagt
man ist es echt schwer so zu klingen wie
man selbst
ich würde einen schritt weiter
weitertreiben und sagen es ist das
allerschwerste mit fast unerreichbar so
zu klingen wie man wie man selbst was
ist mein eigener ton und ich versuche je
weiter ich komme immer mehr und mehr
barrieren abzubauen um zum immer
einfacheren und unmittelbaren thron zu
kommen ja er muss am ende so leicht sein
das ist klopp macht der tornister das
ist jetzt auch vielleicht ein ganz
anderes modell als das von herr messner
da werden schichten das selbst
abgetragen um zu einer unmittelbarkeit
zu kommen die dann ganz und gar
ich wäre ja das ist die frage ob es ob
das gemeint ist in diesem zusammenhang
aber ich verstehe dass leute die kunst
machen oder die sport machen hohen
leistungsansprüchen ausgesetzt sind und
dass diese leistungsansprüche dazu
führen dass man eventuell angst hat ob
man es richtig macht ob man den ton
trifft ob man so wie man es geübt hat es
auch aufführen kann und dass diese diese
ängste dazu führen dass das kunststück
sage ich jetzt mal nicht gelingt und
damit die ängste von einem abfallen muss
man diese leistungsansprüche vergessen
und nach dem was wir vorher und zurecht
gelegt haben sind diese
leistungsansprüche etwas äußeres was von
der gesellschafter an herangetragen wird
und wenn man beim klavierspielen immer
darin verharrt den leistungsansprüchen
der klavierlehrer oder dem bedürfnis des
publikums
gerecht werden zu wollen dann bleibt man
quasi außen orientiert aber jemand der
klavier spielt der markt natürlich die
musik und er sieht in dieser musik
irgendetwas was mit seiner eigenen
lebensgeschichte zu tun hat und wenn es
gelingt das was mit der eigenen
lebensgeschichte zu tun hat in der
aufführung zum ausdruck zu bringen dann
ist es keine außen orientierung mehr
sondern es ist eine orientierung die
quasi aus dem künstler selbst
herauskommt
aber es muss nicht bedeuten dass er sein
wesenskern zum ausdruck bringt sondern
es kann auch eine situative stimmung
sein
also es kann sein dass der pianist an
einem abend wo er eher traurig ist
beethoven sonate anders spielt einem als
einem anderen abend hätte er das in
diesem moment war genau weil er in
diesem moment traurig ist und sich nicht
um die ansprüche seiner lehrer und die
wünsche des publikums schert sondern
seine traurigkeit an diesem abend mit
dem klavierspiel zum ausdruck bringen
kann wegen der hohen autonomie die
erreicht hat und an einem anderen abend
wo er vielleicht eher fröhlich gestimmt
ist benutzt er die sonate um etwas
anderes zum ausdruck zu bringen das
heißt sich ausdrücken zu können als
künstlerin oder sich als sportler
realisieren zu können bedeutet nicht
dass man notwendigerweise an einen
wesenskern glauben muss der dann ans
licht kommt sondern dass man seine
lebensgeschichte in dieser schwierigen
tätigkeit fortsetzen kann ohne äußeren
ansprüchen dabei gerecht werden suchen
eine frau von stimmigkeit im moment als
etwas was man als kern sucht ja würde
ich also wie das man kann beides beide
interpretationen sind möglich und ich
würde die zweite das ist nicht der kern
ist der ans licht kommt sondern dass man
in übereinstimmung mit der eigenen
lebensgeschichte die kunst aufführung
als fortsetzung dieser lebensgeschichte
betrachten kann und nicht als ein
herausfallen jetzt mach ich mal was ganz
anderes jetzt dreht sich nämlich auf
dass das das ist was gute kunst
auszeichnen er erlebt sagt ja noch was
anderes er sagt ich versuche diese
barrieren die ich mir selbst aufgebaut
habe zu lösen ich versuche die
geschichten die man falsches ich spielt
zu überwinden und immer immer näher an
etwas ranzukommen so ein sympathischer
prozess bis gar niemand mehr spielt
sondern nur noch der ton klingt ja dass
das ist also das jetzt noch ein sehr
viel komplizierter gedanke der etwas
damit zu tun hat dass wir uns in der
regel von der umwelt abgrenzen und sagen
also da
da bin ich und da ist der tisch und da
ist die andere person das aber leute die
sich beispielsweise mit einem klavier
beschäftigen oder die sich mit einem
fußball beschäftigen oder die sich mit
einem bogen beschäftigen
diese abgrenzung so schaaf nicht machen
können sondern sie müssen sich auf diese
geräte mit denen sie etwas machen sehr
sehr intensiv einlassen und viele leute
berichten dass diese geräte fast so
etwas wie verlängerung ihres körpers
werden und so wie ich eins werden mit
dem instant wird eins mit dem instrument
was so wie ich nicht darüber nachdenke
wie ich meinen arm zu heben habe darf
ich als fußballspieler nicht darüber
nachdenken wie ich meine wade zu bewegen
habe um zu schießen und darf ich als
klavierspieler nicht darüber nachdenken
müssen wie ich meine finger zu bewegen
habe um die töne hervorzubringen
und da gibt es offenbar gerade des
verschmelzen mit dem instrument und eine
möglichkeit das auszudrücken ist zu
sagen dass man vollständig selbst
vergessen sein muss ganz eins mit dem
ball 1 mit dem bogen 1 mit dem klavier
geworden sein muss damit es wie gerade
gesagt oder flop macht und der ton
einfach entsteht und nicht von mir
hervor
brachte ich weiß von ihnen dass sie
rudern oder lange haben gibt es da in
dieser repetitive tät des ruderns auch
das gefühl ich ruder nicht mehr sondern
es ruht und das ist dann das was man
eigentlich hatten ja sogar im rudern
jedenfalls wenn sie wenn sie nicht im
einer fahren sondern in der mannschaft
gibt es noch eine spezielle ein
speziellen effekt dass sie ohne dass sie
sich absprechen
im gleichen takt und auch mit den
gleichen druckverhältnissen im wasser
das brot beschleunigen müssen und diese
diese dieses ahnen wie man gemeinsam das
boot am schnellsten hervor vorantreiben
kann
das ist nicht nur eine eine
verschmelzung sage ich jetzt mal mit dem
mit dem gerät und mit dem wasser indem
es schwimmt dass man genau merkt welche
bewegung jetzt hier am günstigsten wäre
sondern das ist auch und das klingt
jetzt vielleicht etwas komisch eine
verschmelzung mit den anderen leuten im
boot dann nochmals schwieriger
das ist noch mal schwieriger deshalb
muss man kilometer um kilometer fahren
damit man merkt wie die anderen sich
bewegen und ohne sie angucken zu müssen
sie zwar hinter einem wenn man vorne als
schlagmann im boot sitzt und trotzdem
muss man merken was können die anderen
noch und wies der druck gerade im boot
oder was ich bei meinem mannschaftsspiel
wie fußball oder eishockey oder
basketball dann können sie jetzt ja auch
nicht mal die lage peilen bevor sie im
pass spielen sondern müssen einen der
läuft jetzt da in diese richtung und
passt jetzt mal der wird es schon
kriegen also dass auch quasi eine
intuition für das was in der mannschaft
möglich ist und was nicht
aber da könnte man sagen das klingt
jetzt ein bisschen esoterisch so wenn
ein rudertrainer sagt werdet 1 mit dem
boot vielleicht sagt er auch nur halte
ich an die technik und mache was ich dir
sage also es gibt ja auch eine
künstliche formen diese synchronizität
zu erzeugen die gar nichts mit
selbstaufgabe sondern voller
konzentration auf bestehende vorgaben zu
tun
ja das also dass das was schließlich gar
nicht aus und man lernt dass in dem man
auch genau auf diese weise vom trainer
ermahnt wird und dann wird das ganze
wiederholt und wiederholt und
wiederholten wiederholt und dieses
diese diese diese dieses repetieren
derselben handlung
das führt zu einer spezifischen form der
selbstvergessenheit das heißt da ist ein
merkwürdiger effekt dass das des
umkippen vom drill der eigentlich etwas
mit äußeren ansprüchen zu tun hatten wir
eine zumutung dass dem ema sagt wiech
rudern oder oder schießens oder was auch
immer
und dann gelingt es plötzlich und man
merkt es gelang genau in dem moment in
dem ich weil ich zum tausendsten mal
gemacht habe gar nicht mehr gemerkt habe
dass ich es gemacht habe ja also das
plopp gemacht wie weh es ist eine es ist
etwas was es auch bei der sprache gibt
bei der sprache er hat man diese diesen
umkehrpunkt durch die bedeutungs
verschwinden
also wenn ich tausendmal schellfisch sei
schnell helfe chef chef des shell chef
scheffel irgendwann habe ich noch den
klang da und denke nicht mehr an den
fisch im wasser
also durch durch das repetieren findet
ein kippen
statt aus dem aus dem kommunikativen
signal wird ein reiner klang und eine
bedeutungs entleerung bedeutungs
entleerung genau unser selbst entleerung
führt dann und wenn man sagt ja du musst
du musst schnell das wasser fassen damit
du keine zeit verschwendet du darfst dem
bruder nicht nach links oder rechts
ausweichen war das boot wackelt und so
weiter dann ist man da macht man da
quasi alle möglichen bewegungen und
versucht sich zu koordinieren und so
lange man an alle dieses an all diesen
kram noch denkt gelingt es nicht richtig
und wenn man es ganz oft gemacht hat und
dann quasi aufgehört hat man also die
anweisung zu denken dann fängt es an zu
gelingen
jetzt zwei bereiche in denen diese
selbstfindung durch selbstvergessenheit
erreicht werden kann die kunst sie
nannten den sport es gibt aber noch
einen dritten in sehr viele menschen
heute in repetition unter anleitung
eines meisters aus führen nämlich das
meditieren
und sie meditieren auch oft sie
schreiben auch darüber
das ist nochmal ein drittes modell wenn
man ja sich auf kein instrument oder
irgend etwas widerständiges konzentriert
sondern die man erst mal sehr ganz auf
sich selbst oder ja also vielleicht
wirkt das von außen so aber es gibt es
gibt etwas bei bestimmten techniken
schon ein instrument nämlich den eigenen
körper also es man benutzt wie das von
einer philosophin gesagt worden ist den
eigenen körper als hebel um die welt
anders wahrzunehmen und das ganze ist
aber noch komplizierter weil man das
macht
um etwas zu tun was auch nichts
hinausläuft
also auf die frage warum hast du warum
spielst du klavier kann man eine ganz
gute antwort geben ja also um ein
schönes musikstück zu gehör zu bringen
um einen wettkampf zu bestehen
vielleicht der an der zenn meisterwerke
der 1960 gestorben ist hat auf die frage
bringt mir das meditieren was warum
meditiere ich geantwortet
um diese geisteshaltung in der man nach
warum fragt zu verlieren
das heißt es ist quasi eine selbst
widersprüchliche handlungsweise bei der
es darum geht die zielverfolgung
loszuwerden ansagen danach zu streben
nach nichts mehr zu streben
das kann man so sagen aber gewissermaßen
praktisch nicht und deshalb also die
fixierung des körpers und die
konzentration auf eigene körper zustände
und nicht auf äußere gegenstände führt
dazu dass das man merkt dass die
wahrnehmung der äußeren gegenstände
sofern dabei der körper nicht bewusst
ist immer mit einer bestimmten
interessen verfolgung verbunden ist mit
einer bestimmten bewertung das wasser
schmecken das wasser schmeckt wenn ich
diese nadel peaks mich liebst mich nicht
das heißt normalerweise nehmen wir
unseren körper selbst bei der
gegenstands wahrnehmung nicht war aber
alle bewertungen der gegenstände kommt
dadurch zustande dass unser körper durch
den kontakt mit dem gegenstand in einen
bestimmten zustand gerät ein lustvoller
schmerzhaften und in dem moment in dem
sie die aufmerksamkeit auf die körper
zustände richten
werden sie selbst zu gegenständen also
ihre lust und schmerz zustände werden
selbst ein beobachtungs gegenstand und
das bewusstsein dass diese zustände
beobachtet bewertet nicht mehr
das könnte man als gleichgültigkeit
beschreiben
ja was ist der begriff der
gleichgültigkeit der ist in diesem
zusammenhang hofft auch als kritik
benutzt worden dass sich leute in den
zombie zustand meditieren ja nur sie
quasi das sind alles egal wird das ist
ja moralisch heikel man kann sagen da
wird ein kind geschlagen ich bin in
diesem zustand der nicht bewertungen
sagt da wird dein kind geschlagen aber
dass es weder gut noch schlecht sondern
das passiert einfach
ja ja das ist sicher richtig dass das
ein was ist ein tiefgehendes problem was
mit den moralischen den sozialen dem
politischen aspekten dieser dieser
kontemplativen haltung zu tun hat aber
wenn wir einfach nur auf die uns auf
diese kontemplative haltung beziehen
dann kann man sicher sagen dass
bestimmte meditative praktiken etwas
damit zu tun haben dass man lernt das
was geschieht so wie es geschieht
wahrzunehmen und das entspricht dem was
der pianist gerade gesagt hatte man
lässt den ton also viel wie das auch so
gesagt er auch meditiert hat dass man
den ton geschehen lassen muss und erst
wenn man in der lage ist in ton
geschehen zu lassen
passiert wirklich kunst und die
abtrennung des bewusstseins von den
bewertungs zuständen führt zu einer
kontemplativen haltung bei der
quasi die ganze welt wie ein kunstwerk
erscheint jetzt gibt es eine person
vielleicht war es auch gar keine person
die in dieser kunst besonders weit
gekommen es oder der erleuchtete und der
hat ja wenn ich das richtig verstehen
und das ist eher eine frage noch etwas
anderes gefunden dass dieses selbst das
da nimmt gar nicht existiert das ist
eine vollkommene auflösung jedes
gedanken eines stabilen selbst überhaupt
eines wahrnehmenden selbst gibt ja es
ist sehr schwer zu sagen was der bruder
theo ob der theoretische überzeugung
gehabt hat ja das was über ihn
aufgeschrieben worden ist es ja sehr
viel später als ziemlich lange nach
seinem leben aufgeschrieben worden
aber dieses dieses bewusstsein was sich
von dem bewährten den körper zuständen
ablöst
das kann man als ein sehr allgemeines
bewusstsein ansehen also dass das dass
dieses bewusstsein in ihnen in mir oder
irgendjemand anderen raum eigentlich
dasselbe ist und sofern wir selbst mit
unverwechselbarer individualität
identifizieren ist dass selbst nichts
anderes als die lebens und der buddha
würde sagen die leidensgeschichte die
dadurch entsteht dass dieses allgemeine
bewusstsein durch die körper zustände
beunruhigt worden ist und wenn man sich
von dieser beunruhigung befreien kann
und die eigenen körper zustände
beobachtet dann identifiziert man sich
nicht mehr mit dieser leidensgeschichte
und dann hat man sich quasi zum
verschwinden gebracht ich würde aber
nicht sagen dass es dieses selbst das
leidet und nach lust und nach glück
strebt eigentlich nicht gibt also es
gibt es schon es ist nur etwas sehr f&e
meeres was durch bestimmte soziale und
biologische verwicklung entsteht der
familie heißt was nicht ganz stabil ist
etwas genaueres befindliches ja also
sowie eine metapher die da häufig sowohl
im buddhismus wie auch in historischen
literatur verwendet wird ist das
die aufgeraute oberfläche eines teiches
oder eines sees als wenn sie wenn wenn
wenn sich ein see bei windstille
betrachten dann ist ein glatter spiegel
und wenn dann ein wind darüber streicht
wenn sie segeln muss man da sehr genau
darauf achten dann gibt es eine
aufführung und da entsteht quasi ein
muster ja was was aussieht wie ein
individuum er da ist irgendetwas
plötzlich auf dem see entstanden und das
verschwindet aber sobald der wind wieder
eingeschlafen ist und man kann das
allgemeine bewusstsein sich so
vorstellen als quasi eine glatte spiegel
oberfläche und durch die lust und
schmerz zustände des körpers wird wird
diese aufmerksamkeit aufgeraut und
dadurch entsteht quasi kurzzeitig so
etwas wie ein individuelles selbst
nämlich dieses muster der aufführung
auch so wann immer wir ich sagen machen
wir sozusagen wind auf der oberfläche
haben sie denn dass selbst mal erfahren
dass man diese glatt spürt dass dieses
kreuz und verschwindet das ist ja etwas
was sehr selten gelingt und hoffen war
vielleicht nur einen bisher gegangen ist
ja ich glaube dass das gelingt vielen
personen die sich relativ intensiv mit
dieser mit mit meditations- praktiken
beschäftigen
das schwierige im westen ist halt dass
diese frage warum mache ich das ganz
schwer abzuschalten ist und die meisten
menschen die sich der meditation widmen
tun das aus ganz anderen gründen als aus
dem motiv dieser aufbau zum verschwinden
zu bringen weil es viele nebeneffekte
gibt dass man erfrischt ist danach als
hätte man geschlafen
die navy seals benutzen die gleiche
praktik die ich benutze weil die
konzentration eines scharfschützen
hochgeht wenn er sich so fokussieren
kann die man das lernt wenn man sich auf
den atem beispielsweise
fokussiert und in der wellness bewegung
wird es quasi als eine glücks technik
betrachtet als selbstoptimierung
entwicklung genau
ich kenne auch sportler die vor dem
wettkampf eine kurze versenkung gemacht
haben um dann quasi fokussierte einen
wettkampf zu gehen brentano hat bevor
der vorlesung meditiert damit einen
besseren auftritt in der vorlesung hat
also man in der regel wird die
meditation nicht dazu genutzt um diese
auf frauen zum verschwinden zu bringen
und das selbst quasi zum verschwinden zu
bringen sondern sie wird dazu benutzten
sich zu optimieren einen besseren
glücklicheren zustand zu kommen
wir sprachen jetzt lange von der von der
seele von den selbst als eine form der
frage nach dem wirklichen leben da gibt
es ja noch einen zweiten pool die
sogenannte wirklichkeit was bei diesem
herrn und bei den zuständen die
erreichte besonders interessant dass man
sie beschreiben das auch einem buch ist
dass die idee der wirklichkeit als
wirklichkeit auch interessanterweise
brüchig wird oder gar verschwindet sie
nennen das die erfahrung der
bodenlosigkeit oder das nichts das ist
eigentlich die wirklichkeit der
wirklichkeit ja dass das hängt mit einem
aspekt zusammen der mit dieser
aufmerksamkeit die sowohl bei
ästhetischen zuständen wie auch bei
großen sportlichen anstrengungen nötig
ist zusammenhängt dass man etwas was
einem strukturlos vorgekommen ist
plötzlich in seiner struktur erkennt
also ein musikstück dass wir als naive
hörer als eine einfache melodie
betrachten kann eine hohe interne
komplexität haben was man dann merkt
wenn man es versucht gut aufzuführen
ein effekt den man hat der eine einfache
wut die man hat kann einem wenn man sie
analysiert als das produkt einer sehr
komplizierten lebensgeschichte vorkommen
bei der man kein ende kommt ob sie
irgendwie von einer beleidigung die mir
meine mutter als ich vier war zugefügt
hatte noch abstand und die ich jetzt
wiederholt sehe in einer bestimmten
sozialen konstellation
man kann wenn man wissenschaftlich
ästhetisch und vielleicht auch meditativ
die zustände in denen man ist und in
denen irgendein welt gegenstand ist
lange genug analysiert zu der
überzeugung kommen
diese analyse ist kann man ins
unendliche treiben sie hört nie auf
statt zu einem kern zu kommen komme ich
zu immer weiteren schichten also die
elementarteilchenphysik a schein auch
diese erfahrung zu machen dass er neben
größeren beschleuniger brauchen weil es
in dem was vermeintlich einfacher
einfach ist immer noch strukturen gibt
die man finden da ist nichts und die
sucht bohren immer weiter und es wird
immer unübersichtlicher anstatt
übersichtlicher zu werden also man kann
sagen es gibt zwei möglichkeiten wenn
man sagt da ist nichts
oder man kann sagt kann sagen in jedem
kleinsten ausschnitt der welt ist noch
eine unendlichkeit drin und zu glauben
irgendwann komme ich an dem an des
pudels kern an dem was eigentlich dieses
glas wasser oder so ausmacht das ist das
ist eine illusion sondern die einsicht
in die art und weise wie die welt
beschaffen ist besteht eigentlich darin
zu erkennen dass sie unendlich komplex
ist das betrifft ja jetzt ein
übergreifendes projekt das nicht nur mit
diesem sondern auch anderen büchern
diesem letzten jahren geschrieben haben
zum beispiel die lehren der philosophie
verbunden ist nämlich mit der idee was
die philosophie wie wir sie derzeit
betreiben überhaupt bewirkt und bezug
auf unsere wirklichkeit und
selbsterkenntnis und dieses buch heißt
zum beispiel die lehren der philosophie
eine kritik wenn ich sie richtig
verstehe sind sie außerordentlich
skeptisch ob der art und weise wie wir
derzeit philosophien auch akademische
philosophieren in irgendeiner anderen
weise etwas beiträgt uns selbst oder die
welt zu erkennen
ja so die die akademische philosophie
unterliegt natürlich constraints die
etwas mit der konkurrenzsituation
akademischer institutionen ganz
allgemein zu tun haben und
man begibt sich in diese akademische
institution vielleicht auch eine
karriere zu machen und um meiner
karriere erfolgreich zu sein muss man
bestimmten ansprüchen gerecht werden und
das hat oft nicht damit zu tun dass man
merkt ich muss bestimmte anstrengungen
durchführen um mich meine eigenen
komplexität der komplexität anzunähern
sondern ich muss weiß ich bestimmte
drittmittel ein wir haben oder ich muss
zum bestimmten periode artikel
publizieren damit sich vorankommen oder
mit meiner universität vorankommt und
diese dieses eingespannt seien in
konkurrenz situation ist institutionell
die wiederholung das was man quasi in
der midlife crisis oder in der pubertät
erfährt nämlich dass man außen gesteuert
in einer ziemlich schwierigen tätigkeit
vorgeht und es wäre eigentlich besser
nicht außen gesteuert zu sein
das ist quasi die sage ich mal die
oberflächlichste kritik an der
akademischen philosophie dass das
einspannen der philosophischen tätigkeit
in den akademischen kontext in nicht
unbedingt gut tut weil es immer karriere
sehsüchte mit sich bringt und die
letztlich nicht windschief stehen zum
philosophischen er will das würde für
die kunst auch sagen dass ein künstler
sehr ausgesetzt ist den kunstmarkt oder
dem dem zirkus des aufführungs und dass
die gefahr besteht dass das interesse an
der kunst oder an der an der musik
verschüttet wird durch das bedürfnis
eine künstlerische karriere zu machen
und wohin bestände dann aus ihrer sicht
die wahre mission aufgaben oder
vielleicht auch nur das jeweils
personale ziel des philosophierens ja
also ich glaube dass das philosophieren
auf zwei arten sehr erfolgreich sein
kann es kann erfolgreich sein wenn es
einen neuen welt zugang schafft das
führt dann dazu dass in der regel eine
disziplin gegründet wird also viele
disziplinen nicht die medizin nicht die
mathematik aber die biologie die physik
die psychologie
die soziologie sind aus ideen von
philosophen entstanden auf spezifische
art und weise auf die wirklichkeit
zuzugreifen
und in dem moment in dem sich diese
ideen als fruchtbar erwiesen haben haben
sich methodologien entwickelt die dann
in einzel wissenschaften weiterverfolgt
wurden also die geburt der einzeln
wissenschaften aus dem streben des
philosophierens genau das ist das ist
ein erfolgreiches projekt was sie aber
sehr selten realisieren können und was
sie auch nicht erzwingen können
sie können nicht sagen zu einer
philosophischen sagen nun macht mal eine
neue disziplin in den nächsten fünf
jahren ja dass das passiert sehr selten
die andere art philosophie zu betreiben
hat mit dem zu tun was was der pianist
sagte ja damit zu tun eine eigene stimme
zu finden die zum ausdruck bringt was
man selbst für einen welt zugang hat und
daher da segelt die philosophie weniger
dicht an den einzel wissenschaften als
vielmehr dicht an der literatur und wird
sagen es gibt viele suchen die
aristoteles der der einige einzel
wissenschaften gegründet hat ich würde
sagen die vergleichende
politikwissenschaft hat er während die
biologie hat er begründet und es gibt
philosophen wie sören kierkegaard oder
friedrich nietzsche die die eine eigene
stimme entwickelt haben und man kann die
welt biologisch sehen und man kann die
welt nietzsches sehen
man kann die welt physikalisch sehen
oder man kann sie kirche gok sehen und
wenn wir jetzt diese zweite zweiter
linie verfolgen dann sehen wir dass das
große ähnlichkeit mit literarischen
welt zugängen hat wir sagen ja manchmal
dass einem eine situation kafkaesk
vorkommt und das bedeutet dass man die
welt mit kafka sehen kann oder mit mosel
sehen kann
zunächst mal wie eine verfremdung wenn
ich das jetzt gelesen und ich die auf
die straße kommen ja alle jungen männer
irgendwie schuldig und bedrückt vor und
kann sagen das ist eine verfremdung der
wirklichkeit und kein keine freilegung
der wirklichkeit ja es ist eine
verfremdung aber gleichzeitig wenn es
eine haut oder einem autor gelungen ist
in einem text die eigene weltsicht
sichtbar zu machen für für die
leserinnen und lesern merkt man sieht
man auch dieses andere individuum also
wir sehen wenn sie in den jünglingen
dostojewskis roman figuren sehen sehen
sie plötzlich auch dostojewski also
dostojewski konnte sich in seinen texten
selbst sichtbar machen also wie sich der
pianist gar selbst zu gehör bringen kann
können sich philosophen und um ausließ
und lyrikerin in den texten die sie
produzieren selbst für andere sichtbar
machen und das ist etwas sehr
schwieriges aber es ist etwas was uns
auch in erstaunen versetzt
also wenn es eine person schafft sich
nicht in phrasen zu äußern sich nicht in
rollen modellen durch die welt zu
bewegen sondern wenn sie es schafft
einen text oder ein musikstück zu
produzieren der klingt wie noch nichts
geklungen hat aber in dem eine person in
ihrer lebensgeschichte sichtbar wird
dann sind wir ja vielleicht nicht nur
erstaunt sondern auf merkwürdige weise
auch beglückt weiter quasi eben eine
gewisse komplexität plötzlich vor augen
haben die uns so gar nicht
vorher präsent war ist das überdrehte
man sagt dann wäre es ein ziel des
philosophierens sich selbst als
individuum zu einer stimme zu verhelfen
und in dem man das tut andere individuen
individuen in ihrer komplexität
möglichst differenziert sichtbar zu
machen
ja also ich denke das ist ein mögliches
projekt das man haben kann was genauso
legitim ist wie eine für viele menschen
verfolgbare neue weltsicht in form einer
neuen disziplin zu erzeugen
je mehr wir in der lage sind die
komplexität der welt sichtbar zu machen
um so erstaunlicher und schöner kommt
einem die welt vor und das gilt auch für
für andere menschen also emea ein
anderer mensch in der lage ist sich
selbst in seiner ganzen komplexität
sichtbar zu machen
umso froher sind wir in kontakt mit
dieser person also eine person die uns
als charakter maske als rolle gegenüber
tritt das macht uns schwierig also
manchmal wir erwarten jetzt nicht vom
steuerberater das irgendwie als als sich
verwirklicht in seiner steuerberater
tätigkeit als individuum aber es ist
doch auch so und das verlangen menschen
ja auch der philosophie die wollen keine
differenzierte von handlungs regeln
festigkeit orientierung und sie bieten
ein in eine welt an die immer
schwieriger und weniger greifbar wird
während viele menschen gerade jetzt von
der philosophie fordern sagt uns doch
mal wie es ist ihr müsst das doch wissen
ja ja ja das ist die vorstellung dass
die philosophie an ein problemlöser für
das normative ist und dass das berührt
einen 1 1 ein sehr komplexes gebiet das
wir noch gar nicht angesprochen haben
sich das verhältnis von philosophie zur
politik und zu sozialen problemen und
ich will das nicht nicht leugnen dass es
da ein aufgabengebiet der philosophie
gibt dass sie auch teilweise gut bedient
hat also ich will würde ich würde nichts
gegen karl marx sagen wollen
der
der meinung war dass die philosophen die
welt nicht interpretieren sondern in ihr
intervenieren sie verändern sollen
und das hat mit einem aspekt zu tun der
bei der kontemplativen haltung nur so
nebenher vorkommt nämlich wie sollen wir
mit leid umgehen sondern mit mitleid mit
ungerechtigkeit umgehen indem wir uns
aus den entsprechenden sozialen
verhältnissen in die kontemplation in
die wildnis zurück zurückziehen oder
verändern wir die verhältnisse die
dieses leid verursachen indem wir
intervenieren und das ist dass es ein
sehr grundsätzliches problem bei dem ich
nicht sagen wollen würde die philosophen
sollen nicht intervenieren
doch die philosophen sollen
intervenieren wenn sie eine gute idee
haben wie sie intervenieren können so
dass sich die verhältnisse verbessern
ich glaube aber nicht dass die
akademische philosophie im moment
besonders intervention kompetent ist das
ist sehr interessant dass vielleicht
auch bedenkenswerte schlusswort weil wir
am anfang und das letzte frage mit der
betonung der kurze antwort gab es denn
eine lektüre erlebnis das ihn in der
philosophie gezeigt hat ich bin noch gar
nicht ich selbst ich muss mich darauf
hin orientieren eine lektüre die sie die
wirklichkeit neu hat spüren lassen dass
das gab es ganz häufig also die die
lektüre von antiken philosophen aber
auch von vielen versuchen im 19 jahren
also also plattform
und nietzsche waren so als ich 14 15
waren für mich ganz wichtige autoren die
augen öffnen ja er hat bei vielen dank
dass sie heute ganz sie selbst waren
nicht in der sternstunde und nächste
woche starten wir bereits mit unserem
sommerprogramm ihren sieben wochen
zeigen wir ihnen die highlights der
letzten monate sozusagen die
sternstunden der sternstunden ende
august begrüßen wir sie dann mit neuen
sendungen und einen neuen studio jetzt
gleich aber dreht sich erst einmal alles
um den mann der ein gewöhnliches peace
wahrgenommen und es ins museum gestellt
hat bleiben sie also dran einen schönen
sommer und denken sie weiter
[Musik]